Just because they are rich, famous and sometimes
even powerful celebrities, it doesn’t mean
actors cannot be fired.
They’re rich, famous and seem to have it
all so it’s hard to imagine powerful celebrities
It probably happens a lot more than you’d
think.
And sometimes it is a lot worse than you’d
imagine.
Say, for instance, you’re an actor or actress
who has filmed all your scenes and the director
has a last-minute epiphany that you just aren’t
right for the role.
Whether it is a contract problem, money issue
or simply not being a good fit, getting fired
is not fun situation to be in.
Check out
these 10 actors who were fired during production.
Edward Norton in The Avengers
Edward Norton is known for his incredible
work in films like “Fight Club,” where
he played the unreliable narrator and “American
History X” as a reformed neo-Nazi.
Additionally, Norton appeared as Bruce Banner
in the 2008 Hulk movie.
He was expected to reprise his role as the
green monstrous hero in “The Avengers,”
however, Marvel Studios said it wanted another
actor more suitable for playing the character.
Norton reportedly met with director Joss Whedon
and was told Mark Ruffalo was chosen for the
role, citing Ruffalo was much easier to work
with.
Terrence Howard in Iron Man 2
Terrence Howard could have had an integral
part in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, but
all that disappeared in a blink of an eye.
If you remember, Howard co-starred in the
2008 “Iron Man” film as James Rhodes/War
Machine, but was replaced by Don Cheadle in
“Iron Man 2.”
Howard has stated that he had a three-picture
deal and was guaranteed $4.5 million for the
first movie, $8 million for the second and
an undisclosed amount for the third.
However, the studio only offered him 1/8 of
the original agreed amount for Iron Man 2,
which is sadly only $1 million.
Aside from the low ball offer, Howard was
also told the film would be a success with
or without him.
Ouch!
Stuart Townsend in Lord of the Rings
Stuart Townsend is undoubtedly a talented
actor, but he just hasn't landed a role that
earns him an A-list status.
This could be because he’s missed a few
major opportunities.
The biggest came when, after months of intense
training and preparation, he was fired from
the role of Aragorn just as filming was commencing
on “Lord of the Rings: The Fellowship of
the Ring.”
At the very last minute, director Peter Jackson
decided 26-year-old Townsend was too young
for the role and replaced him with Viggo Mortensen.
Unfortunately, Townsend missed another big
opportunity when he dropped out of the Marvel
blockbuster “Thor.”
Megan Fox in Transformers
After appearing in both “Transformers”
and “Transformers: Revenge of the Fallen,”
Megan Fox was replaced as Mikaela Banes.
Back in 2009, the actress made several remarks
about director Michael Bay comparing him to
Hitler.
Apparently Fox said to Wonderland magazine,
“He’s (Bay) like Napoleon and he wants
to create this insane, infamous mad-man reputation.
He wants to be like Hitler on his sets, and
he is.
So, he’s a nightmare to work for.”
After the interview was published, Fox was
fired and replaced with Rosie Huntington-Whiteley.
Anne Hathaway in Knocked Up
“The Devil Wears Prada” actress Anne Hathaway
was originally cast as lead Alison Scott in
Judd Apatow’s 2007 comedy “Knocked Up.”
In the film, Alison ends up getting pregnant
after a one night stand with Ben Stone (played
by Seth Rogan).
But it looks as though Hathaway had an issue
with the birthing scene, which she described
as too graphic.
In the end, Apatow decided to let Anne go
and replaced her with Katherine Heigl.
Dougray Scott in X-Men
You can’t mention X-Men or Wolverine without
picturing Hugh Jackman’s face.
For over 15 years, the Australian actor has
appeared as the metal clawed hero in over
seven films.
But it would surprise you to know he was not
the first choice for the role.
Russell Crowe was originally eyed for the
role but his salary demands were too high.
Next, Dougray Scott was cast as Logan.
However, playing Wolverine required a sequel
and Scott’s conflicting schedule with “Mission:
Impossible II” made it quite literally an
impossible mission.
So the role was given to Hugh Jackman.
Sean Young in Batman
Kim Basinger embodied Vicki Vale in Tim Burton’s
1989 “Batman” flick.
It was like the actress was made for the role.
But she wasn’t the first choice.
Sean Young was initially set to play the journalist.
Unfortunately, the “Blade Runner” actress
could not continue on in the role after she
broke her arm from falling off a horse in
rehearsal.
Samantha Morton in Her
Imagine the 2013 film “Her” without Scarlett
Johansson’s husky tone as Samantha, the
intelligent computer OS.
Well that almost happened!
The movie had already completed filming when
the Spike Jonze decided to replace British
actress Samantha Morton with ScarJo.
Apparently Morton’s performance “wasn’t
working for what the character needed.”
Ryan Gosling in The Lovely Bones
In Peter Jackson’s 2009 film, “The Lovely
Bones,” Ryan Gosling initially earned the
part of Jack Salmon.
Gosling decided he needed to gain weight to
play the grieving father and put on 60 pounds
by melting Haagen Daz ice cream and drinking
it.
When Gosling arrived on set the first day,
Jackson was all but impressed.
The two apparently had different ideas of
what the character should look like and in
the end Gosling was replaced by Mark Wahlberg.
James Purefoy in V for Vendetta
James Purefoy was originally cast in the role
of V in the 1988 DC/Vertigo Comics series
“V for Vendetta.”
About six weeks into filming, Purefoy complained
about wearing the mask saying he couldn’t
do it for the entire film.
Ultimately this led to him being replaced
by Hugo Weaving and the rest is history.
Amanda Seyfried in As the World Turns
The blonde bombshell Amanda Seyfried is best
known for her role as the ditzy teen Karen
Smith in “Mean Girls.”
But what you may not have known is Seyfried
got her start at 11-years-old on popular soap
operas like “All My Children” and “As
The World Turns.”
Unfortunately, Seyfried’s acting in the
latter was so bad she was fired.
She played Lucy Montgomery on the soap and
revealed she was so uncomfortable on screen
that the only option was to ship the character
off.
As devastating as that is, it did prompt Seyfried
to take some acting classes and enhance her
skills.
What do you think of our list?
Know of any other surprising firings in Hollywood?
Join the discussion in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.